this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king in the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
christina ellis ramsey personality
newest ramsey personality is joining me
for a segment here we want to make sure
we you guys all get to know her and uh
you'll be hearing a lot more from her in
the coming weeks and coming years
and we look forward to that welcome
thank you thanks for having me so
christina has quite a storied background
before she joined our team she had a
best-selling book called confessions of
a scholarship winner and how-to books
and how to graduate debt-free
she started a website called
collegeninja.com that we are melding
into the ramsey stuff as well
and she is a college ninja without a
doubt she uh secured over 500 000
dollars in scholarships went to
vanderbilt and got her degree and got a
master's degree as well and all of it's
supported by scholarships so she's
walking living proof that you can go to
school debt-free and that it's possible
right yes absolutely yes if you are
willing to fight for it and put together
a strategy there is no reason that you
need debt for college you can do it
so
lest someone think that this is a uh
uh
privileged situation that sets you up
for this none of these scholarships were
athletic
none of them were academic
um
your dad passed away of cancer when you
were seven
and so you're being raised by a single
mom and she sat down with you and had a
conversation yes the first day of my
freshman year of high school my mom sat
me down she said christina i love you
and i believe in you but there's just no
way that i can support you financially
once you graduate from high school so
you got to figure out your own way to
pay for college and at first i was
shocked i thought why are you telling me
this i am a freshman in high school what
can i do about it but at the same time i
knew that she was just trying to help
and cast a vision for me
yeah and she's she's your mom i love
your mom i mean she's just old school
she's venezuelan is that what it was yes
yes from venezuela came here married an
american and your dad and he passed away
and so she's like scratching and clawing
immigrant mentality get her done baby
you know kind of woman and this is this
woman's a force of nature
she's a anything but a victim and wasn't
going to allow you to be oh yeah she's
such a fighter and the thing is that she
emigrated from venezuela in her 20s she
actually got a scholarship to come here
to the united states and she grew up in
a pretty rough background kind of the
slums of venezuela so she in her
perspective was like i got you this far
so now what are you gonna do like here's
the baton you better run hard and fast
to get to the next level yeah you
already got a whole bunch more than i
got so no whining and here's what we're
gonna do but she didn't just dump it on
you as a as a ninth grader
and leave you uh
penniless or
or hopeless she actually was your
cheerleader and really gave you a system
she was an incredible cheerleader and i
actually love that she told me in ninth
grade i think that all parents need to
have those conversations as early as
possible because she let me know the
reality of what i was going to face and
she gave me time to come up with a
strategy you know i read every book
every resource i interviewed alumni from
my high school to figure out you know
what does it take to win scholarships
and how can i stand out in the process
you know she encouraged me to put
together a plan and strategy and then i
implemented it all throughout high
school i just continually what did you
do
i got involved in extracurricular
activities i worked on building up my
grades i took the right classes i took
up leadership roles i volunteered you
know i wasn't a star athlete i didn't
have perfect grades so i had to figure
out you know how can i stand out in the
process and something that i did is i
volunteered a ton i did over a thousand
hours of community service when i was in
high school and i continued to create
opportunities and just look for ways
that were unique to stand out
also doing things that i love i
encourage people you know when you're
trying to get involved in high school
and stand out in the process don't just
do things because they stand out in the
scholarship application process do
things that you love when you're doing
things that you love you're going to
want to pour into them and then
naturally stand out
and then you filled out scholarship
applications and essays like daily yes
my mom and i kind of lived in the
library and that's another cool thing
about my mom is like she didn't just
tell me what to do you know she would
sit with me at night and we would talk
about applications we would do the
research together on the computer and we
would just she would be my cheerleader
when i was applying you know i would get
bored sometimes and be like oh do i have
to do these applications come on and she
would you know help me take a break and
be like you know let's go grab some
coffee let's just like make this a fun
process and let's do this you know she
helped me stay pumped up
yeah and so how many scholarships do you
think you applied for i applied for
around 50 scholarships which actually
now that i do this for a living and i
talk to people about scholarships i
encourage people to apply for a lot more
you know i was very fortunate that i won
some very big scholarships but i love to
see students applying for 100 or 200
scholarships because the more you put
yourself out there the greater chance
you have of winning yeah and 100 at 250
gets a lot of money yes it adds up it
adds up incredibly fast yeah and you can
go through school
debt free now we've got the book here
debt free degree by anthony o'neil that
uh we teach people how to go to school
debt free
college choice is a big part of it uh
but if you get five hundred thousand
dollars worth you don't even have to
worry about college choice right yeah i
was very fortunate i was able to go to
vanderbilt university for my undergrad
in belmont for grad school completely
debt-free and they're not cheap schools
both of them are expensive
yes both of them are really expensive
yeah so but if you if you don't get 500
000 worth you have to you need to choose
a school that is within the budget of
the money you can get your hands on
whether it's scholarship money or
working or wherever you're going to get
the money you choose a school that's
within that budget and that is the
number one thing that drives people into
college debt yes i always want people to
explore their options that's the thing
is that there are so many choices out
there i feel like a lot of students get
stuck on this idea of a specific school
that cost 50 or 70 000
and you don't have to go that direction
there are so many different options for
a debt-free degree you know there are
tons of free community colleges nowadays
there are a lot of employers that are
offering incredible tuition benefits a
lot of employers are now offering free
college if you work for them plus you
can still earn money while you're
employed so it's it's really cool to see
all of these options growing and
expanding the first time i ever saw that
ups was doing it in louisville in their
home office and you could load trucks
and they pay for you to go to school at
the university of louisville
and um you know that's was an incredible
benefit now a ton of people are doing
that with the current upside down world
we've got on labor and labor shortage
and it's 15 an hour to work at target
they'll pay for your college and so you
know probably 10 or 15 other major
employers are offering that benefit
and so if you want to go to school
debt-free you need to be willing to work
you need to be willing to set aside time
and apply for scholarships you need to
be very careful about your college
choice oh and did i mention you need to
work
yes
and that's what's so cool is that you
can literally work and make an income
while getting a free degree so it's like
you avoid student loans completely
and you're making money which it's like
that's kind of the best of both worlds
you can follow christina at i am
christina ellis on twitter and on
instagram
you'll learn more about scholarships and
more about ramsay money principles and
as she has joined the money section of
the ramsey personality team and
certainly with a specialization in this
but you'll hear her talking about all
the other things as she joins this show
in the coming weeks and months and joins
our lineup and our our events and things
you'll see her everywhere welcome to the
team christina thank you thanks for
having me i'm thrilled to be here gonna
be gonna be a great ride this lady is a
smart lady she's uh way smarter than me
so you put her and john deloney in the
same room my iq goes up just walking in
there so there you go this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality joins
me this hour open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five he's my
co-host
he's also the host of the dr john
deloney podcast
one of our fastest growing properties on
ramsey networks right now everyone tuned
in and listening about relationships
this is the show where we talk about
relationships we talk about your work we
talk about your money we talk about you
and if you want to get in the phone
number again triple eight eight two five
five two two five true or false it's
possible for you to become a millionaire
what if i told you the answer is
it's possible and it's up to you
research shows you don't need a
six-figure income
you don't need an inheritance
and you don't need to win the lottery
to become a millionaire
people just like you
research this real data not opinions
reach millionaire status simply by
following our baby steps we call them
baby steps millionaires
baby steps millionaire's book that came
out last week number one bestseller
shows you exactly how to do that and
with our best year ever bundle you get a
copy of the brand new baby steps
millionaires book and you also get
signed up for financial peace university
and the premium version of every dollar
in ramsey plus
when you use these tools and you follow
these simple steps you will
build wealth you will build your bank
account you will eventually become a
millionaire the typical person is 12 to
17 years so learn about the best year
ever bundle by visiting ramsey solutions
dot com slash best that's ramsey
solutions dot com slash best our phone
number here to talk is triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings with
free samples free shipping and new
promos all the time use the promo code
ramsey to get the best deal today's
question comes from hannah in illinois
she says i've always struggled with
emotional spending to fill a void in my
life in stressful situations
my husband and i started dating he was
debt free which prompted me to want to
get out of debt i was able to pay off
four grand before we got married and
then my husband paid off the rest of my
five thousand dollars debt
we were debt free for 10 months until
the pandemic hit and the stress spiraled
into spending on my credit cards i
thought i would be able to pay them off
but i kept spending and the shame of the
debt overwhelmed me so i kept it a
secret my husband was angry when he
finally had a discussion about my debt
and i closed my accounts how do i how do
i handle the shame of past mistakes and
avoid emotional spending i want to do
better in our finances and work together
but my husband doesn't believe i am
willing to change
man dave there's a lot here um first i i
don't know that her husband's uh angry
about the spending as much as the
dishonesty and the deceit in the as we
call around here financial infidelity
here i'm sure he was upset about the
spinning but more of the violation of
trust
um
so the way i've heard guilt and shame
framed is guilt is
when you say i've done something
that violates my moral boundaries
shame is when you say i am
like not i cheated i should feel guilty
about cheating on a test
i'm a cheater i carry that shame around
with me and
so when anyone says how do i get rid of
my shame i think you pull your i say i'm
gonna pull myself away from these set of
behaviors and i'm going to say i'm going
to stop doing these things
your husband uh
doesn't believe you're willing to change
because i don't see here that i'm that
you're willing to change
i see i hear dave in this language this
over and over um
i'm just out of control with this thing
it controls me nothing i can do about it
and i don't have a choice in this stones
i stone cold disagree with that yeah i
if you label yourself which is shaming
you're right if you i'm an emotional
spender
then you're no longer uh uh held
accountable for the fact that you're
just not being an adult that's right
like i'm six two i have to bend over to
get into a
a four foot you know
fence let's say like that's a that's a
fact i'm six foot two
she is not an emotional spender six foot
two right she's labeled herself an
emotional spin right and that's how she
has chosen to cope with things in the
past well and it lets you off the hook
for for the pain of the responsibility
to change that's right if you label
yourself well i've got this disease
i've got a problem and i've got this
disease and so i'm stuck can't help it
i'm just the way i am so hannah you know
what you do you get rid of all of your
cards you get rid of all of your
internet access i mean how far do you
want to go to keep your marriage how far
do you want to go to stop this kind of
behavior
do you want to get to spend some time
with the counselor and get to the root
of what why you feel the need to do i
mean you could go to the ends of the
earth to fix some of this behavior you
do some emotional spending and you've
had some immaturity and some weakness
that has led you to that you are not
defined as an emotional spender and
that's what you've got to change the way
you just said that is so empowering i
don't know how the culture got sideways
in this yeah but sometimes because we
want to be victims instead of victors
but you know do you realize how like
what you just said is so much more
empowering than oh honey you've got an
emotional spending problem disorder it's
not even a disorder but yeah well that's
what she wants to say versus you made
some bad choices
struggled with emotional spinning to
fill an emotional void yeah yeah well i
mean i'll struggle with chocolate chip
cookies to fill an emotional void too
but i'm not one yeah
my tendency is to i have the same one my
tendency is to emotionally eat so i've
got to set up some you're not a gummy
bear oh god almighty i can get after
some gummy candy but so here's the thing
i have to set up a lot of boundaries in
my life
ask people i ask people in this building
to hold me a kindle that well yeah
here's the thing when you go through
something like that that is not an a
fact instead it's a perception right
then what you have to do is you have to
change your mindset about it and so
um i i think there's a whole lot of hope
for her and what her husband is afraid
of and it's coming out as anger is that
she's going to stay in this hole because
she believes she is this whole
and she hasn't gotten to the root of i
lied to my husband yeah yeah well and
and on top of that um
you know i just straight up as an adult
who legally can do stupid things did
some stupid things right call it out
yeah just say i did that
when i went bankrupt you know i went
bankrupt because a barter's thinking
much money
you know because i was an idiot i got a
phd in dunb and i signed up for a bunch
of short-term notes the stupid bankers
took my head off well i put my head on
the block that's how they took it off
you don't stick your head on the block
you don't get it taken off
so um american express calls my house
now it's a wrong number i mean we don't
deal with these people anymore because
i'm not going to ever be back so you
have to have a moment in time where you
say i'm sick and tired of being sick and
tired never again right
never again that is not who i am i don't
act this way and you start and it's not
some kind of false new age
affirmation or something but you never
again label yourself
as an emotional spender you label
yourself as someone who used to spend
emotionally
i've done that a couple times in my past
i don't do that anymore no james clear
would say label the opposite i'm
somebody who's a steward of my finances
yeah and i'm going to literally be good
with money now that's right and i'm
really good at staying out of debt and
building wealth so what are the
practices i'm going to put in my god
that went bankrupt that's right
and there dave there are times when i
will not go into a gas station because
you know what's in gas stations gummy
bears oh my gosh gummy candies if i
haven't slept if i'm tired if i'm in a
bad mood i won't go in because i know
that when i go in there can't go in a
bar if you're a drunk that's right
that's right go sit down at the bar
where everybody else is ordering a
double
if you're drunk and go well you know i
used to drink a lot but now i'm putting
myself in a situation here where i'm
going to drink again don't put yourself
in you can't do that if you've got a
history of that and you've got a history
of this and i had a history of
misbehavior with money but it and it was
somewhat greed driven somewhat emotional
maturity driven somewhat identity driven
there's a lot of things that drove it
but all those things are things i chose
right and i can just decide to unchoose
them right
and go but and we had a good call the
other day you and i did about a lady
said how do i break my poverty mentality
and it's it's the same thing only i
think we're probably a little bit more
sympathetic for that yeah than i am with
this one uh yeah she grew up with a
model yeah she grew up with a thing and
she's never seen anything else and
and she hasn't labeled herself with that
she said how do i not be that that's
right yeah and that's a much better
question
than than uh you know how do i work how
do i do better in our finances uh you
don't you decide you're better yeah
and then you work on your finances with
your husband and you may need to for a
period of time uh you need to get out
all the credit cards and chop them up
and you may need to have a real clear
weekly discussion with your husband
about where all the money in the house
is cash with you so that he rebuilds
trust over time because you lied to him
that's right
and there's nothing wrong with that i
mean everybody makes mistakes like you
made hannah we're not shaming you for
doing that but for god's sakes don't
label yourself i'm trying to unshame you
i'm trying to give you your power
another one i get all the time is i'm
not good with math
yeah so i can't do money right well by
god people can do all kinds of sixth
grade math and sixth grade maths what it
takes to be good with money
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
on the stage the debt free stage in the
lobby of ramsey solutions evan joins us
hi evan how are you good how are you
better than i deserve where do you live
pittsburgh pennsylvania all right cool
and how much debt have you paid off sir
168 000. whoa how long did that take 21
months oh this is rocking and uh your
range of your income during that time
from 65 to 292.
now this is bizarre okay so what in the
world do you do for a living and what
happened to this income so i am a
executive recruiter for a large
third-party recruiting firm
and you've had a good year had a good
year man had a pretty good year
holy crap yeah
yeah the great resignation has worked in
your favor a little bit yeah so i think
wow the uh the shift actually happened a
little bit before that so i was working
in midland where i believe john knows a
little too well in the oil field yeah
and so i switched into the recruitment
and 2020
was weird for recruiting to say the
least and then in 21 it got a lot better
all of a sudden yeah yeah pretty much
out of nowhere so you went from the oil
field some of the hardest work on the
planet to being a recruiter and you go
from 65 000 to 300 000. yup dadgum dude
yeah
mike dropbox and it's an air
conditioning down dancing i like it i
work from a home office not in the
middle of a frac site oh wow whoa
awesome
life is this is amazing so why the
change why the change well money
wow well you can make your money in the
yeah so i actually have an engineering
background and the work i was doing was
not engineering driven at all okay and
so
the shift came both to get from midland
back to pittsburgh and then also because
you don't have to be in the middle of a
heavy industrial setting with your
fingers on the line yeah literally yeah
it's hard work too yeah and on top of
that i mean physical labor and uh not
that recruiting from your home office
isn't hard work but
there's a difference between getting a
callous on your dialing finger but um so
uh 168 000 what kind of debt so it was a
bulk student loans there was a nice car
in there there is a little bit of credit
card debt and then the kgb
oh we got behind with the irs how much
did you owe the irs it wound up being
like 2 800
and so this was dumb college kid i
worked a similar oil and gas thing
between semesters 1099 i did not know
that i was 10.99 found out three and a
half years after the fact in the middle
of going through this and so that was uh
that was a murphy's law situation did
you buy your fancy car when you on the
field too i bought my fancy car about
six months before i left a few
groups of people
overspending on cars like roughnecks
yeah no it's uh it's live the stereotype
for sure what did you buy toyota 4runner
okay all right what did y'all want it uh
i was like 31 ish okay that's not too
bad i was expecting 50. okay that's what
they are brand new yeah and so the uh
but the student loans were over a
hundred and something yeah it was like
so the pre the davish year i had before
that 21 month period
student loans were like 170 or 180
that in that 21 month timeline it was
actually only about 115 of it okay all
right wow
and uh boom knocked it out man so what
happened you get to pittsburgh you
obviously started making great money you
got a great shovel to get out of this
big hole you're in and a whole paradigm
shift how did you get connected with us
how did you start this whole process
yeah so a buddy of mine from college uh
he was telling me about the podcast and
stuff like that him and his wife had
done
like 60 or 70 grand in less than a year
and he i was hoping i was gonna be able
to find the conversation for the
pictures and the the quote that i would
give from him he was like there's this
guy in tennessee he's a redneck money
guru
yeah i do too you're accurate
description
a little bit on the nose but go ahead
yeah and he goes he goes you should
check out this podcast because you've
been talking about the the student loans
for ever and ever and i know you've been
hitting them hard and this might help
really light an extra fire and
you know the the money didn't come
immediately with the recruiting you know
it took about
12 or 13 months of that 21 to really
build up to
consistent commission checks and stuff
like that that help pay for all of it
but
his
intro to the podcast it was
three hours a day every day listening to
the podcast constantly yeah
wow i need to change my moniker to
redneck millionaire dude i think that's
i think that's i don't like the guru
thing so just redneck millionaire and
that's better than dave ramsey himself
which people always come in miami you
would have sold a lot now i'm now called
himself if it was if it was a redneck
millionaire as if i would be someone
else how how hard was it to
towards the back end you're getting
commission checks that are legit right
how hard is it to take a 25 000
commission check and not go buy
something nice but just dump it off your
student loans so
that's the the discipline thing the
adults devise a plan and follow it kids
do what feels good
so
look at some of that that's like some
redneck wisdom right there
man sayings from a redneck man i'm gonna
write a letter write a little book i
love it this is good i like it good man
i'm proud of you appreciate it way to go
who's your biggest cheerleader
uh good group of my fiance amber sitting
to the side way to go amber and then uh
what we have self-proclaimed to be the
big shovel gang is my buddy eric and a
couple other friends of ours who are
like this guy yeah these are some guys
making some coin and being smart with it
yeah big big podcast advocates oh well
we're honored man that's very cool shout
out to the big shovel gang there yep i
like it young guys making bank and doing
smart stuff not being idiots with it how
you going man that's good that's good
life hey that's how you change this
country i pay my my student loans off or
do i buy a bunch of bitcoin and gold
well done yeah no bitcoin absolutely no
bitcoin
it would be worth half that 25 would be
worth 10. so yeah yeah there you go all
right wow man this is incredible well
done what do you tell people the secret
to getting out of that is
just sticking to the plan follow it it
works the the 80 behavior is absolutely
the case because what john was saying
you know you you wake up at the end of
the month and you've got a 30 000
commission check in your bank account
how do you not go and want to buy a car
but then you've got you know 80 grand
left on your student loans
it feels a little bit better to get rid
of that hey you pointed out something i
i i don't want i don't want to fly by it
you've got a group of guys that are
walking through this with you
how important is community and
accountability in doing any hard thing
in life yeah that's absolutely huge so
being able to bounce an idea off of them
this is what i'm thinking about what do
you guys think and yeah
i'll let you stay on the plan yeah
exactly of all the things you learned
stay obviously you're going to keep on
the money journey you're going to be a
babysitter you're going to be one
tomorrow afternoon right by the way
you're by the way you're earning money
and taking care of it but don't forget
the importance of having other men in
your life that can speak into it that
you'll listen to and you'll submit
yourself to and vice versa that's
important man good for you that's a very
it's it's vital the people that i know
that are successful you become who you
hang around with so he's hanging around
with the big shovel the big shock i just
love the name and it wasn't just the
debt to i mean i cash flowed uh the
wedding that we're having in april i
wait there was something else in there
cash flow this the trip that we took to
nashville
[Music]
were
you know we were able to get 15 down on
a house
and got lucky with the market not being
too crazy and
before we know it we'll pay off chambers
is your fiance is amber dead free she's
close okay so when you get married
you'll not get out yeah so we're gonna
knock that out in probably six months
good and we'll know in april yeah pretty
much in april
between now and then yeah yeah that's
very good very good man you guys are
rocking this way to go brother
yes yes yes so proud of you man well
done thank you well done you're a hero
and uh you're doing some you're going
places man this guy's smart as a whip i
love it all right very very good stuff
all right got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you as john said you'll
be one in 20 minutes so we need to make
sure you have the manual that's the next
chapter in your story on how to do this
and uh you're you're a rock star young
man i'm honored to meet you and uh man i
need to do something with the big shovel
gang there's got to be something how
many of them are there uh including
myself four oh okay good we're sending
babysitter's millionaire books to all of
them with you that sounds good yeah
we'll sign them all for all of them yeah
we got to do something this is just a
good great idea integration see i i'm
i'm more interested in the the redneck
millionaire t-shirt that i'm going to
have printed up
i need credit on the licensing for both
of those yeah well i think you said
redneck guru and i ain't going with that
so you don't get no licensing i'm going
with mine but
this is fun i love it i love it i love
it all right count it down 168 000 paid
off in 21 months making 65 to 292. let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
i'm debt-free
[Applause]
yeah baby way to go brother i love it i
love it i love it i love it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today jackson san francisco hey
jack welcome to the ramsey show
good morning uh mr randy how are you
better than i deserve sir how can we
help
i want to know how do i use cash
distribution from a mutual fund
133 thousand dollars
okay what do you need to do with it what
do you want to do with it
uh well
let me give you a little bit of my
background
i my net worth is about 10 million
dollars
and uh i have no debt
uh
everything is paid for
and mostly
my investments are in
real estate good for you amazing job and
then did you start with nothing and
become a 10 millionaire
most likely mostly yeah i i become a 10
million dollar
millionaire in 10 years uh i'm at the
retirement age of 72 and uh i'm
withdrawing
i'm getting my first year rmd to this
year
that's why i withdraw the
133 000
from mutual funds which are putting six
thousand dollars before
uh 30 years ago
and i didn't touch it
i got 233 000 wow
and
i have
uh because of the tax situation of the
rmd i withdraw that
from the um mutual fund the last year
right you're required um it's required
distributions at
i have to do something
if you're 10 million if you have 10
million dollars and you're completely
debt free and you have 33 000 in your
hand the and what do i do with it the
answer is anything you want you're a
genius
i
okay but it still doesn't matter
if you burn it in the middle of your
front yard your life doesn't change
well
i have a few options i want to go by you
to see if it's a it's a good investment
or not okay number one i can buy a
tax-free uh you know bound or mutual
what else what's number two uh the other
alternative is to buy a long-term care
uh you don't need a long-term job you
have 10 million dollars
i don't need long-term care yeah you
have 10 million dollars you can afford
long-term care
you know it seems it only cost me six
thousand dollars uh i know but it only
costs
fifty thousand dollars a year and the
average person uses it for two and a
half years
that's two hundred three hundred
thousand two hundred thousand bucks
three thousand bucks max out of your
pocket out of ten million three percent
of your net worth you can self-insure
through this don't pay you don't give an
insurance company money self-insure
through it besides that a guy like you
is probably going to hire somebody for
in-home care anyway private care you're
probably not going into a nursing home
yeah well this this this london care
painting home uh too yeah that's fine if
you want to buy it no i would not buy it
no i would not buy them
what's your other choice
um those are the two choices i'm
thinking about you have another splurge
i'm not spreading it
okay i'm driving a two thousand dollar
car and uh i have i'd be happy with that
i'm not even buying a car okay i want
you to buy a car your car sucks
you have 10 million dollars you need to
go buy a car with this money you don't
have to spend a hundred thousand dollars
on the car but you ought to not be
driving a two thousand dollar car when
you have 10 million dollars that's just
you need to have something more reliable
a little bit more enjoyable to get in
and it like starts every time and all
that kind of crap you know so nothing
wrong with the two thousand dollar car
when you're broke and you're trying to
get out of debt but you sir have lived
like no one else and now you're able to
live and give like no one else the
second thing i would tell you to do is i
would be generous for something
that's right i want you to find someone
or somewhere that you can put ten
thousand dollars or thirty thousand
dollars that you give it away to be a
blessing to someone and i want you to
enjoy the smiles on their face and the
change in your heart rate when you do
that
because it affects your body to quote
john doloni when you do things that are
stressful and when you do things that
are good
it changes the chemistry of who you are
and so i want you to give some and i
want you to enjoy some and then with
whatever's left you ought to invest it
if you want to put it in a muni bond you
can but dude you didn't make any of this
money doing investments like muni bonds
you made all this money with mutual
funds and real estate and so i i would
dance with the girl that brought me on
the investments uh if you want to buy
another piece of real estate fine if you
want to uh you know use some mutual
funds i'd do that but i i personally
wouldn't put anything in a muni bond the
returns suck they're tax-free but they
suck
and uh i just wouldn't do it i'm 61 i'm
right behind you a few years i don't
have any muni bonds on a single bond uh
nor am i planning to in my life
so so dave what's what's the moment when
or maybe there never is you've earned
your money
like you've you've done well and you're
in your 60s now let's say you hit the
magic is there a number when
you stop
putting money into your investments and
you just start enjoying it and giving it
away or will that always be part of the
rhythm because now we're talking great
grandkids right
you you want to keep the rhythm now you
can change your percentages sure but you
always ought to every check i get i put
it on one of three i put some
of the check on all three things some on
investing
some on generosity and some on enjoyment
yeah now the the amount that i put on
enjoyment these days is percentage-wise
very small but the checks are big right
and the life is already good before i
got that check right so i don't need a
lot of to have a unbelievably luxurious
life right you know i mean not not mtv
music video life but i mean i've got a
great life with a small percentage but i
always want to make sure i stop and go
i'm going to enjoy the moment yep just
made some money that's right and the
second thing is we're always going to
increase our giving we're always going
to increase
our uh investments but these days the
larger percentage goes to generosity but
i still do some to investing it's
systematically still growing i don't
need more so even the kids and grandkids
don't need more right but the more
investments you have the more they throw
off and the more generous you can be
there you go okay so it's the goose that
lays the generous eggs there you go
after a while i mean you're creating a
family foundation and creating a family
of that has a net worth that is
continually generous over time not just
yourself and that's not just
you know buying somebody's gas at the
gas station which is always fun too of
course that's where it starts yeah but
yeah you need to you need to always be
doing all three and that's with your
four-year-old
and with your 84 year old there you go
okay spencer is in orange county uh
spencer how are you
hey dave how are you doing i'm doing
good great how can we help
uh so i am a young father well i'm not
necessarily young i'm 34 years old and
i've got one boy who's two
and another one on the way yay good for
you yeah thanks guys and i gotta get out
of california i can't stand it here
so
my wife just paid we just paid off our
student loans
and uh we uh want to move back to utah
with family
the housing market in utah is
terrifying but my whole life i've always
just taken it one step at a time and
we're out of debt we have no debt uh we
just paid off student loans so now we've
got about 60 000 saved for a
down payment on a home you do not own a
home in orange county
we do not own a home in orange county
so you're moving and you're buying a
house
yeah that's that's the plan that's what
you want to do but okay i guess my is
that like
they've never been great with money but
we do have money saved up and
you're 100 debt-free i think you're
great with money
well okay so don't say that don't say
that ever again yeah you're in rare air
brother
and then the other thing you have an
emergency fund in addition to the 60 or
is the 60 all you got yeah
no 60 for the house payment alone and
then 30 000 for about just other things
so we have about 30 000 emergency funds
good we haven't um
perfectly what trimester is your wife
and
sorry say that again what trimester is
your wife in
wait you said she's pregnant i did not
yeah yeah oh so trimester sorry she's in
the second trimester she's 21 weeks
along okay you don't move until the baby
comes
yeah we're going to have the baby first
and we're planning on moving early 2020
through husband advice um
one guy
wanna
move a pregnant lady that's fun
yeah i don't i just don't know i just
don't know what to do next i mean we
want to find a baby and go to utah and
buy a house
you can do it is that is it as simple as
that it is as simple as that you are you
got it man or if you move if you move to
utah and rent for a year nobody's gonna
your life will still be great yeah and
then buy a house out during that year
sometime once you get to know the area a
little bit and you get a little bit
through some of the craziness of a
newborn i'm assuming you got a job lined
up over there spencer but long as you
got income lined up
load up the trek truck and head to
beverly
it's the opposite actually now we're not
going to beverly anymore but there you
go
this is the ramsey show
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
dead is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney of the doctor john deloney show
and uh best-selling author of the book
redefining anxiety is my co-host today
as we talk about your relationships your
work your money and your life right here
on the ramsay show like we do every day
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five
five
two two five dawn is with us dawn's in
cincinnati hi don welcome to the ramsay
show
hi thanks for taking my call we love
your show thanks for what you do well
thank you how can we help today
yeah um so i have a niece she'll be the
first one to go to college and her
family
and
um
she wants to be a teacher and we listen
to your show enough to know
the college should coincide with the
career path you choose and when it comes
to what you're willing to pay
she has received an eighteen thousand
dollar scholarship but she would like to
go to xavier university
which is about 52
a year
um and she wants to graduate with her
teaching degree
and my brother has tried over and over
to tell her that that is not a good
choice she's even gotten a full ride
to a quote unquote in her mind lesser
school
he's even tried to bribe her
saying go to that school and i'll pay
for your final year at xavier and then
you can graduate from there she's just
not listening to any of us and we don't
want her to get
you know having 80 to 100 thousand
dollars in debt
being a teacher
so do you have any resources or what
have you done in the past to maybe help
these kids to realize this probably
isn't the best decision
duct tape yes
[Laughter]
and baling wire you can go to tractor
supply your local tractor supply and get
all of your get a chair duct tape into a
chair
i'm kidding
i'm kidding i'm tempted but oh my gosh
so she's a stubborn brat teenager
definitely yeah
and usually those are forms by stubborn
parents and she's already
an education snob
so john john has a phd in higher ed and
has been the
dean of students at expensive schools
and um other various important positions
at expensive schools so how do you fix
this john
well you got you got a couple of
problems here one is is
usually this attitude is formed
somewhere in the home
right
so
often parents will try to wait till the
last minute and correct behavior that
they may have been a part of and so
if there's any sort of elitism or
they're dumb i can't believe it driving
that car that's where a parent sits down
with a teenager and says hey my attitude
has been wrong for the last 15 years and
i'm sorry right that's not going to cure
this problem overnight but that's like
you've got to start with that level of
humility and normally not always but
this kind of attitude that i see in 17
year olds and 18 year olds come on man
that usually comes somewhere from inside
the house the second thing is is
this
some places you can some you can't some
it's hard i would re i would sit down
and say i will not cosign for anything i
will not at some point you got to draw
some really hard boundaries um i'm not
going to support this you're not going
to take my car with you you're not going
to take my phone plan with you some of
these things sound draconian and mean
but you're trying to keep a kid from
making a hundred thousand dollars
mistake
right with another with an unformed
brain right their brain is not fully
formed at 17. you're holding a a uh
uh
a full ride
to a state school right it's it it just
doesn't work mathematically it doesn't
work professionally
and here's another thing i would do i
would get a teacher
that this person that she trusts
oh that's good it's got student loan
debt and you say i will pay for the
dinner or i'll the parents will pay for
coffee
and go say go sit down and ask them if
it's worth it because i had this happen
my friend randall
i had coach basketball at the high
school level and then i was working at a
university and his son was five or six
and he said this is so obnoxious will
you go outside and tell my son to
dribble a basketball like this i said
why don't you go tell him he goes
because he's gonna listen to you right
now and so there's something about
somebody else saying it sometimes and so
send her out with a teacher that she
respects and looks up to and that
teacher will hopefully set her right
that's good thank you for that but at
the end of the day
parents really like i i've heard this
once i heard a thousand times well i'm
not going to like take away their car or
their phone i'm still going to put 500
in their account every month i just
think they're making a bad decision and
i always know you're financing their
back that's right look at the parent and
say
how far are you willing to support your
kid making bad choices yeah right i mean
i'm not going to take away their car
they're only doing cocaine i mean it's
not a problem
like you know that's the kind of thing
so yeah it's uh and going to a private
school does not mean you're doing
cocaine but you know what we're saying
here right you're financing the the the
lack of wisdom there so what we used to
tell our teens uh
about various things because
was that uh i would look at one of them
that was losing their mind and they're
16 years old and i would say listen
there's two people that live inside your
body right now
there's a four-year-old and a
34-year-old
if i can talk to the 34-year-old we'll
have a discussion about persuasion
if i'm talking to the four-year-old i'm
going to freaking tell you what to do
and i'm going to make you do it
physically now like i would a
four-year-old you're going to behave in
my house
now we can discuss this and i can tell
you why that's important and why you're
building character and we can have a
persuasive discussion or
i can just make you now what do we want
to do here
and so and i'm going to do that here i'm
going to just sit down and say this is a
dumb butt asinine decision
and i feel like i'm negotiating with you
like you hold any cards in your hand you
don't hold any cards i have all the
freaking money i own your life you are
not an adult i still get to tell you
what to do
and so now we can have a discussion like
two logical adults about this and xavier
is not evil but the number of schools
that she applies to go to you apply to
go to school to honey that actually care
where you got your teaching degree is
precisely zero
unless you want to work at xavier
and then they will care that you went to
xavier but short of that you know you're
signing up for cincinnati city public
schools
zero chance you get the job because you
went to xavier versus went to the other
school absolutely precisely zero there
is no data on the planet to justify this
aristocracy crap in higher ed that these
famous schools that are triple quadruple
5x
expensive are worth a penny more than
the others they're not
now might you learn a little bit more
maybe but the idea that you're gonna do
better as a teacher the idea you're
gonna your career is gonna be on a fast
track because you paid 5x is zero
it's a it's asinine
i wouldn't i to know why why why why
does she want to go to xavier why is she
so set on it
well
um she said that it is one of the best
programs uh
in the state for teaching so so here's
what i want to do i hear that from
teenagers all the time
prove it
show me
sit down and show me what what the
rankings mean where the f i want you to
prove that it's a hundred thousand
dollar difference
why is this car worth 100 000 more than
this other car show me prove it through
17 year old proven both of them will get
you to the market that's right
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today many of you have been
filing your taxes with the same software
for years but you're sick and tired of
having add-on fees and them trying to
sell you everything else under the sun
loans and credit cards and everything
else you've probably seen all the
tax software ads saying it's free with
the big companies but the reality is for
most people it's not free
and by the time you realize you don't
meet the quote free criteria you put in
too much time to start over somewhere
else so you pay up folks are making a
killing off of you and we think you
deserve better that's why we're offering
ramsey smart tax so you can file your
taxes online without paying more than
you'd expect it's a very simple pricing
structure it is what it is
very inexpensive very easy to do but you
got a switch
ramsey smart tax includes every form
that you need no hidden fees no
surprises have a promo code right now so
you can file the federal part of your
taxes for free and if you have a beefed
up thing you'll pay a little more but
the federal parts free with a promo code
so be sure if you prefer to have a
priority support extended audit
protection you can go with a premium
version for just 20
that's a deal so if you're ready to
ditch these other guys
surprising you with fees and all kinds
of other garbage save on your taxes go
to ramsey ramseysolutions.com smart tax
get started right now ramsay solutions
dot com slash
smart tax
jason is with us in louisville kentucky
hi jason welcome to the ramsey show
hey guys thank you both so much for
taking my call i appreciate it sure
what's up
well dave i
i'm really thankful to be
because of you living
a really enjoyable uh debt-free life
good for you and um i appreciate all
that you've done uh to help help me get
there
i'm 47 years old and i am
i work part-time as a pastor in a church
and my payment
from the church is actually a house to
live in
includes all the utilities and
i have virtually zero housing expenses
and that is my payment i'm bi vocational
so i i work elsewhere and i work
i make about 40
42 000 a year
and so again i'm i'm fully through baby
step three this is my year to start baby
step four uh to be able to start socking
away uh money for the future
i'm single i'm a little kid
i am single okay yep i'm divorced uh
unfortunately but uh it's where i'm at
in my life
i have two adult kids um neither of them
chose college
they
have both joined the workforce and
they're doing fine in their industries
and so
i'm a little confused on a couple of
things kind of what maybe a next the
next baby step actually is for me
uh because i'm i'm uncertain if
you know
where exactly my ministry career will
take me um it could be that i end up
moving elsewhere and you know living in
a parsonage kind of long term
um
uh i just don't know if you know if i
should really be kind of setting aside
money for a house
or if it's okay to just sort of be in a
rental situation indefinitely
um so where where exactly i land in
terms of baby steps you know five and
six i'm not really sure good for you and
so you've done really well
congratulations done great job well the
uh the thing is you know free rents free
rent we're not gonna argue with free
but what we've got to think about is
what you're going to be doing when
you're 65 what you're going to be doing
when you're 70.
can we do when you're 75. and we have to
think ahead on that
and a lot of pastors that have a long
time
long long-term uh
parsonage situation uh getting a mess
when they retire
yeah
you live
and uh you you know so let's say you
retired at 65 and you lived to 85 you
have 20 years of rent increasing during
that time plus rent has increased during
the time you did this so what you've got
to do is you have to start saving for a
house you don't have to buy one okay
but you start saving for one and you
know and then depending on what your
uh parsonage offerings are
with this with this situation or other
situations in the future
then that will activate whether you
actually purchase or not
if you actually got an
awesome
pastoral opportunity great income great
uh situation
strong
governance in the church and you wanted
to be there and you can move into that
ministerial that pastoral situation
there's no personage and you got a
hundred thousand dollars in a mutual
fund for a house then you would go buy a
house
and you wouldn't have to think about it
oh i don't know if i can take this great
job because it doesn't have a parsonage
race right right so you make sense yeah
i want you to be able to make the
transfer or be able to retire
but at some point in the equation before
you die you're going to own a house
because it stabilizes your older years
sure sure
now then that all makes that all makes
perfect sense now in the
with the income that i have um in the
low 40s um if i'm if i'm stocking away
15 that's about you know about 6 000 a
year or so
for retirement um i is there a good
recommended percentage that i should
look at by the end of the year to to say
this is my house fund no or um no it's
whatever you want to
obviously the bigger the house fund the
better the situation but obviously the
bigger the house fund the less that's
left over for you to eat
out of 40k right right so it's a
straight it's a straight trade-off
yeah
if you match the retirement you put six
thousand away for a house hey you'd have
60 000 plus all the growth you probably
have 200 000 in 10 years
if you matched it um in good mutual
funds and so but i don't know if you can
do that or not and still have a
reasonable life that's 12 000 out of
your 40 and you've got taxes coming out
but you don't have any housing expense
um and you don't have any utility
utilities so you know that gives you
that's pretty much like having a 60 000
job
so um
you know i think you could probably do
that but uh i'd want to be trying to do
that if you can make your budget work at
that but obviously it's kind of the
equation is the more you put in the more
you're going to have
yeah and i think there's it's good to
differentiate between long-term renting
and long-term free house
right those are two different things i
would never tell you a long-term rent
right i tell you a short-term ramp sure
until you don't have to right uh but
until you're not broke because broke
people don't need to buy houses but
but free house we'll sit there in the
freezer for your house that's right i
mean you sit there for 30 years and free
house and pile up money and so then when
it's over and you retire you go buy a
house that's right but i have i've
counseled with way too many
pastors and ministers i've got nothing
who got trapped in two things and the
two things knocked them out was they
have unbelievably wonderful hearts and
their generosity to people who come come
across their path is
bonkers good
and uh then the uh
and the second thing is they've been
sitting in the parsonage in some cases
and they've done nothing about housing
so between their generosity and nothing
about housing then they lose the
parsonage upon retirement
they're really up a creek that's exactly
right and uh it leaves them
like basically they got some retirement
savings but they're also broke right and
that's nowhere to live yeah yeah and
it's a problem it's just a real problem
so
just be careful hey i want to take a
second
congratulations man your book crushed
got it man your book
the team did a great trifecta yeah but
you wrote a great book man it was uh
it's congratulations yeah
i'm i'm proud of and i'm proud of our
team the marketing i thank you if you
didn't know babystep's millionaires was
number one on all the lists
last week everything so there were some
juggernauts out there too man like you
came in on top
there's some big brothers some real
authors what's going to be some real
authors no i'm just saying there's some
big guys that i if i had been planning
it i would have said let's not do it on
that weekend man you can yeah honestly
glenn beck's a friend of mine and i
would not have launched a book the same
week he did yeah and we did accidentally
and if if he and i had both known it we
would have scheduled around it
but we just didn't didn't compare notes
on that because neither one of us wanted
to bump heads with the other one every
human on the planet now has bought a
copy of atomic habits and that book and
but i mean you came across all of them
man yeah it's just really really james
is a friend oh i love james james is
incredible atomic habits is a great book
yeah so yeah i mean like the top three
right now one two three or
i i don't know if james knows his plan
or not but i bet he does i don't know i
wouldn't be shocked if he doesn't so uh
congratulations man that's really that's
a big time good guys good guys and
donald miller had about come out last
year mcdonald's great author
so a lot of great stuff happening and i
didn't know his was coming out but and i
know him good but
whatever
all right thank you thank you thank you
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage james and kathleen are
with us hey guys how are you good thank
you welcome where do you guys live
we're from houston texas
good to have you welcome and how much
debt have you guys paid off we have paid
off a hundred and thirty three thousand
and forty four months
in 44 months yeah very good we're in
houston
uh south ellington area yeah good cool
and your range of income during that 44
months we went from 127 to 153 cool what
do y'all do for a living
i'm in the hotel industry
i'm a marketing manager with the
insurance firm great very good cool so
what kind of debt was your 133 000
i was a mix of credit cards uh car loans
personal
loans
lawyer fees and then the bulk of it was
my school loans so you were like normal
yes just normal people pretty good mix
yeah walk along here make 127 000 broke
yep yep okay so what happened 44 months
ago what was the wake-up call how'd you
get connected to ramsey
so we were married in 2015
um around that time you happen to come
in with the rest of your
uh financial team your daughter and a
few others that's a grace church yeah
yeah i remember so we attended that it
was just kind of a really big push for
us and then harvey hit in 2017
and
when we realized hey insurance is gonna
not gonna cover it
savings not gonna cover it um
it was a really big wake-up call for us
to say we need to
wipe it wipe the slate clean and
make a new future for for our family wow
okay cool so you kind of knew about the
stuff but the hurricane and the
aftermath of that was the wake up call
we said okay we got to get serious yeah
we had to hit ground zero of course
okay all right but yeah once we realized
we had to take a personal uh loan out
just to help cover what insurance
couldn't and the depleting of the
savings i don't think we ever wanted to
feel that way again right right it took
you right down to the edge yes yeah and
so what got torn up the interest didn't
cover
just
in general it was some electrical um
it's also the package you know i think
you have certain insurance packages in
terms of flood insurance that you're
going oh no flood insurance you got
flooded we had flood insurance just
again i think some of the cos or some of
the expenses were a little bit higher
than we had expected right um so that's
what was
a horrible thing to go through and to
add financial problems on top of it
makes it double bad and then um finding
out we're pregnant six weeks later after
this
of course you did yeah why not yeah wow
very so so
you all make a great salary and when
you're digging out of a hole like this
over
several years
your friends look at you like you're
crazy yeah how how is that y'all are two
young good looking folks y'all are
hitting it in houston having fun and you
got to say no to ball games you got to
say no to concerts
man walk us through that how is that
it's tough uh it really is
you know you get a lot of the family
even aside from the friends they just
they don't get it they say well
you you know you've got the extra cash
you have to have the extra cash and you
know or just put it on a card and
you know we we really had to put our
foot down and say no
tear up the cards cut them up
just keep paying on them paying on them
you know we'll we'll do the movie night
at home
you know
yeah and it's hard when family reaches
out and say hey can you help we know you
know you're doing well can you help us
out with some money or we need some help
or you know cousin so and so that's hard
right yeah very yeah um i will tell you
we love to travel um and we traveled on
somebody else's
you know a credit card every time and
that was the hardest part for us is uh
four years without or the 44 months
without the traveling
um so this is our first you know
and stuff before you take the chance
welcome to nashville i love it thank you
so for folks listening who who can't but
they're hit like i can't tell my friends
no
what does it feel like to get those
checks deposited and you have no other
bills and they're just sitting there
looking at you it's beautiful yeah it's
got to be bananas right it is surreal
because you're so used to um paying on
something and now we're on baby step
three and just putting that in the in
the bank account it feels
very freeing it's um there's a little
little bit of liberation in our marriage
where we just don't have to worry about
anything if there's an emergency that
comes up
we just pay it and it's not even a
conversation anymore and and you get to
keep your own money yeah that's so cool
what an amazing idea yes yeah
so um we even had a
vehicle mishap you know a couple of
weeks ago and it was one of those
situations where
we look at each other and go
well the emergency emergency fund is
there yeah and you know we like see you
pay it and and you move on you just keep
keep trucking turns a crisis into an
inconvenience yeah yeah
you guys are fun way to go guys
incredible awesome who were your biggest
uh who were your biggest cheerleaders
outside the two of you
you know it was really
a couples we had to be each other's um
i'd say cheerleaders and accountability
partners because it was very difficult
for our family and friends to understand
they were amazing cheerleaders it was
like cheering on for a team you didn't
know
you know what they were doing but
i think in terms of understanding we did
have we were in fpu at a grace church
and
they are church members really
understood okay yes please keep going
keep going um but uh it was each other
that really kind of put each other
through the ringer in terms of you know
who's the spender who's the saver how do
we control that and um how do we push
and and complete this goal and so that
really helped out did both of you grow
up in homes that were not different yes
oh yeah i we did not understand the
concept of money in my home so i see
those two beautiful little ones over
here what's
what's it like
knowing if they're going to grow up in a
home that doesn't didn't go through what
you all went through i mean you'll turn
you'll put it in the work for a couple
of years and and their whole life's
going to be different because of that
yeah i want to say that that's great
yeah isaiah after a while i was like mom
we don't have to go out to eat we can
eat at home or
he's he's he really understood very
quickly what it is to keep money in the
bank
um not be debt free and we're constantly
talking about money at the dinner table
which we think is healthy i mean we need
to talk about money more regularly and
understand
what what um
what it means yeah um but i'm so proud
of y'all man where'd it go you guys
where'd it go touchdown
well done well done how's it feel now
that you're free
well it feels great i mean like she said
this is honestly our first family
vacation in four years yeah you know
aside from
maybe an overnight stay was it worth a
couple hours right oh yeah yeah very
much worth it
it's you know it's it's out of pocket
it's cash and you know we go back to
work get another paycheck and just keep
keep trucking you know we don't have to
worry about
you know when the bill shows up whoa
that was that nashville trip or or
anything else like that christmases are
kind of best vacation that there is fun
yeah the best vacation that there is one
doesn't follow your home right right and
that's just awesome way to go you guys
we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you as we were just
discussing number one bestseller and
that's the next chapter in your story go
and become millionaires yes sir
something else maybe your bunch hasn't
done before not many bunches have i'll
just tell you that it's a special thing
you guys are incredible and copy a total
money makeover for you to give to
someone disturb their life it'd be a
good thing for them to be a little bit
disturbed so good stuff very very cool
congratulations all right let's bring
the kiddos in what are their names and
ages right quick uh isaiah he's 12 and
veronica jane is three all right
there we go veronica jane has she got
this figured out
yes sir
i love it all right 133 000 paid off in
44 months making 127 000 to 153 count it
down let's hear a debt free scream three
two one
[Music]
[Applause]
hey veronica janey had that down hey not
bad at three well done dialed in the
family tree has been changed i love it
that's what happens man that pretty
little girl she has no idea what her mom
and dad have done oh man powerful isaiah
does he knows yeah he's old enough he
got to see the ark and feel it and now
his language has changed his thoughts
have changed man
yeah
so rachel was about that age yep you
know
when we did that and it's just
uh you look now where she is and where
her kids are yeah you really did change
your family tree it's powerful this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality
co-hosting today he's hosted the doctor
john delony's show
and uh you ought to tune into it on
ramsey network's podcast it is uh
exploding in popularity and you get to
ask questions about relationships and
all kinds of mental health things and
you can today as well if you want to
jump in the phone number is triple eight
eight two five
five two two five john's in kansas city
hey john welcome to the ramsey show
thank you sir i appreciate you taking
the call
my wife and i pastor small church and uh
we've been fpu coordinators and uh have
trained other people in that
thank you matter of fact i'm not saying
it's for accolades but i uh every time
we marry someone we give them a copy of
the total money makeover and wow write a
note in there to follow the biblical
principles that are in this book and
many of them have gotten debt free
my issue today is
i'm 66
i don't have much money uh saved for
retirement
we don't make a lot of money
like i said we pastor a small church
there's been
times we've had to
skip taking a paycheck that kind of
thing my wife does work outside the home
and we're both
receiving social security now
so it supplements our income but um i
don't have a lot of money saved we're
just concerned about you know we're
going to have enough money to live on
porn and falls and
we're debt-free except for our house we
don't know a lot of money on that
what do you owe on the house
oh 85 000 on the house and it's worth
600 and how much nest egg have you got
about 30 35
thousand dollars
yes okay
all right and what's your household
income these days
uh we're about seventy thousand dollars
uh including everything okay
um and are both of you planning to stay
in the same uh
work situation for the next few years
yes yeah i i plan to stay here you know
it's uh it's not a career choice with me
it's actually a calling and i appreciate
that
otherwise i might
might had something that had a better
look for something that had a better pay
package but it's really it's really not
about that it's about ministering to
people absolutely and this is just where
i'm at have a great heart and so uh you
know what i would tell you is i got two
goals for you in five years
perfect i'm ready for you get the house
paid off and put a hundred thousand
dollars for mutual funds
okay still not gonna be still not going
to be enough
but you'll be 71 and you'd have
170 approaching 200 000 in there with
the growth of the 35 if it's in mutual
funds
and um so you'll be approaching 200 000
and i paid for 600 000 house
if you can't make it at least we know
you can sell the house and move to a 400
000 house
well absolutely yeah we considered that
i wouldn't do it today but that's your
fallback plan but if you could get the
house paid off and put 200 away
i think you could make it
well uh i'm we're we're fast-tracking
the house we're paying an additional
eighteen hundred dollars a month against
the principal and it looks to pay out in
two and a half years that's perfect
and meanwhile meanwhile you've got to do
more than that in addition
into retirement because i need to get a
hundred and five years that's 20 000
bucks that's another 1500 that's another
1800 a month
okay so i need to be putting another
1800 away into i just made that number
up pastor i mean i just made it up it's
not it's not a trick number i just was
looking at a 70 000 income
and i thought how much can can we
squeeze out of this turnip
okay okay and i'm thinking there's no
magic to i mean if i could have you have
do have a million when you retired i'd
do it but i don't see that in the
numbers i'm trying to do something where
you can eat
and still pull this off and get some
margin between you and the wolf
okay
okay and so that's reasonable yeah so if
you saved 18 if you saved 1800 that'd be
20 000 you did that for five years
that'd be a hundred thousand plus it
will grow some during that plus your 35
will grow some during that so that'll
bump you pretty close to 200.
okay in your mutual funds and then you'd
have a paid for 600 000 house you're
almost a millionaire at that point
i never thought about it like that
yeah awesome well that's a five that's
five more years of working like you're
working now her too
okay perfect
well i just need to get a hold of one of
your elps and help me with the raw thing
i don't quite understand all of that so
jump on smart vester smartvestor at
ramseysolutions.com and thank you for
your heart
and uh your service
and you know we're just talking about
that a minute ago with parsonage is a
little different subject but
uh gentle big heart call call a god on
his life without a doubt and he's
staring down the barrel of retirement
he's got 30 000 bucks in the bank yeah
all right luckily he's got a house he's
got a great guy do something about it
and good news is he can do something
about it still um it's not going to be
fancy we can do something about it so
the house may end up being the answer
before it's over but hopefully not
hopefully we can work it through without
selling it if they don't want to sell it
but he even held that with an open hand
you hear that yep this guy's spiritual
maturity is amazing beautiful man
beautiful man love it cynthia is with us
cynthia is in des moines iowa hi cynthia
how are you
hi dave doing great thanks for taking my
call sure um i just have a quick
question so
i am on
i am hoping to get on to baby step four
really soon
so my question is around baby step four
um i'm wanting to contribute about 15 to
my 401k great hoping like this next
paycheck or possibly in february
um but i'm noticing that the market is
well it's on the toilet so
should i really contribute at this time
or should i skip it and move on to like
something else or when i was a little
kid
my mama would take us to a store called
kmart
and kmart would in the middle of the day
run these little sales they call them
blue light special blue light special
they would turn on a blue light over the
top of the
whatever area and uh you could go over
there and get you a coffee pot on sale
or whatever that's what you're that's
what we're having right now darling this
is called a blue light special you need
to buy water it's on sale buy while it's
on sale
okay so buy it okay so you know why
how old are
you i'm 40-ish okay 48.
own it own it i'm 61. i'm already proud
of it so there you go but the uh
yeah so here's the thing uh uh
in 20 years
where do you think an average
of companies that sound like this
apple coca-cola
mcdonald's
boeing
microsoft
home depot
an on average as a group now there'll be
some one or two that fail
but on average as a group an aggregate
of that group 20 years from now are they
going to be worth more or less
well ideally more
well not only ideally there would be
that's what has always happened in
history 100 percent of the time so far
in the american stock market's history
now obviously the world can fall apart
and we can just blow this whole thing up
called america but if anything stays
similar to what it is
20 years from today it's going to be up
and you will be glad that you bought in
the cold winter of 2022
when the market was freezing to death
and down
because
of whatever was going on out there i
haven't even seen is there something
going on how far down is it i don't even
look i dropped 500 points in one day the
other day but it's just it's back and
forth it's out of 30 000. 500 points
used to be a lot it's not anymore but
yeah yeah it's uh ukraine and uh and
biden mumbling and
they can't nobody here you know nobody's
getting uh idea that he's gonna do
anything and so the market's just
unstable geopolitical crap always
destabilizes the market it always has
i mean this little thing happens on the
other side of the world and pump all of
a sudden because people just have this
little black cloud following around on
wall street just waiting for the next
thing playing on the next bad thing and
then their psychological as it can be
but uh um
bitcoins in half oh god who knew
who knew that was gonna happen
and so anybody with investing wisdom of
more than eight to ten years yeah yeah
that's true but um yeah it's fairly
fairly easy predictor but fairly you
know easy predictor and this is just a
you know
it is a geopolitical driven it's not
economic driven and it's not profits the
profits of the companies involved have
not changed so are they suddenly worth
less right
no they're so worth what they were worth
it's just they're scared they might be
down in the future because of war with
russia or china or destabilization of
the political environment all that kind
of crap
so do i think all that's going to happen
nope
i think there's going to be problems and
there's going to be times when there's
not problems and the market's going to
go up the market's going to go down and
i only people get hurt on a roller
coaster are those that jump off in the
middle of the ride
dr john dolone good hour good hour to
ben kelly and james in the booth i am
dave ramsey your host we'll be back with
you before you know it
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit
theramsieshow.com and register we would
love for you to come to nashville and
tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality best-selling
author is my co-host today we're taking
your calls they're free and some say the
advice is worth exactly what you pay for
it phone number is triple eight eight
two five
five two two five we'll be talking about
your relationships your mental health
things in your family your money
your work your career we talk about your
life right here on the ramsay show
triple eight eight two five five two two
five heidi is with us in atlanta hey
heidi welcome to the ramsay show
thank you for having me and talking to
me today how are you
sure what's up
um i'm in a little bit of a predicament
um i'm coming to the realization that
i'm
having to possibly make some
decisions that are not only financial
i'm having trouble understanding you can
you speak directly into your phone
please
it sounds muffled hey
are you
can you hear me now yes ma'am a little
better go ahead and try again
tuck bolt
um yeah it's just you and me and dave
like 10 million other people it's good
yeah exactly
um i can't speak too loudly because my
husband's downstairs and i don't want to
be interrupted by him
um
so
i'm in a situation where um
my husband's not wanting to work on our
finances together
um this last two and a half years he has
not been contributing towards our
joint account at all
money is completely separated and uh
recently he informed me that
um if i want my financial situation to
change i have to do something
about it
um because i've suggested to him i've
been listening to you for the last
month or so here and talking about how
if we're going to get out of that we
need to work on it together
um i sent him different shows that
you've um released and in order for him
to listen to it he's just not on board
with it
um what i had
i'm sorry why does he not want to
combine your finances
um
he says that he's got a plan in place
that works for him and um it does not
include you
yeah so how long has he been having an
affair yeah
um
our finances basically have been always
separated
that wasn't what i am
i
i don't know of any
particular situation where
he is having an affair
are you safe
um yeah in my home i'm i'm okay i just
can't speak loudly okay
you can't what can't speak loudly
um so
you just called two guys
listening to how you are having to speak
in your own home
out of fear of a man
who calls himself your husband
and i need you to hear from me who's
also a husband sitting next to another
guy who's a husband
that safety can come in the form of
physical safety and it can also come in
the form of psychological safety where
you don't feel welcome in your own house
and dave's question about
is he having an affair i need you to
hear
hear the behavior
hear what your husband's trying to tell
you through his behavior
that is you are not a priority his
priorities are somewhere else
and he is disinterested in
a relationship with you
correct
right
and it's heartbreaking and i'm saying it
real direct and i know that's hard um
but you are not safe
at all you know that right i'm not
telling you that you don't know you know
that right
yes i know that and this is part of
the last four months has been very
revealing
there you go and so dave's question
about an affair that that was to be my
first question too something has changed
in this marriage it was already separate
and we already would have poked at you
for having different accounts
something else has changed either he's
about to leave or he already has left or
something has shifted or he's in trouble
he's got an addiction issue
um something else has shifted he's in
love with something else
right
um
his phone
um politics
um there's a lot of
different things that are distracting
him but we are all in the same house
together we ever since covered including
the kids
how many children do you have
two girls and what is your income
well
right now it's not where it could be
it's about 40 000
what could it be
if i went back to my former career that
i left to try to do this rv life with
him
um i could be making upwards of money
on my own
so maybe what she could be making
upwards of 90 on her 90. i didn't hear
the 90. okay i'm sorry and um
how old are your children
13 and 9 okay can i ask you a real hard
question
yes
is this the picture
of
love that you want to communicate to
them
no it's not and that's i mean i've been
you know wrestling with this like i said
for the last four months and
after speaking to some of my friends and
coming to the realization that
you know not only is it financial abuse
it's my mental health it's my children's
mental health
it's all of it it's this is not the
person my parents raised
um
my dad i was completely i bought this
house on my own single um i was
completely debt free when i got married
and that has changed okay and i want to
get back to who i was before yeah so
here's what you're gonna have to do
um your friends aren't who walk through
you with this except as friends but you
need to get a good counselor yes so you
need to go see a marriage counselor
starting today
that is a strong person that will try to
help you save your marriage if it's
salvageable
that will give you some a verbage and
some positions to remind you you're not
crazy because you got two guys who are
saying you're not crazy yeah okay and
we're both we both know this stuff okay
so um you need to get a counselor that
can guide you through this you don't
want to do this off of a radio call and
you don't want to do this off of your
friend's opinion over a glass of wine
you need to get a counselor in your
corner that can give you some ways to
explain to your husband
that will amount to ultimately an
ultimatum a boundary a boundary that
says you are going to re-engage
or you're going to disengage we're not
going to play here in the middle
and i'm not going to be abused at this
level anymore
and you got to have someone help you set
that boundary not two guys on the radio
but you're not crazy and you need to do
this and you need to do this right now
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
how many of you are stressed out about
your retirement savings these days
well
should you be concerned are you worried
about the stock market dropping you need
someone in your corner to help you with
this stuff well i think you do
i have people in my corner we recommend
a smart vester pro if you're a smart
investor you have a smart investor pro
in your corner these are investing
professionals that don't work for me but
they have been vetted by our team very
carefully they will have the heart of a
teacher
and they will recommend
information and investments just like
you would hear me do here on the area
like i do personally as well
to learn more about that go to
ramseysolutions.com
smart vester remember when the stock
market goes down if it's going to come
back up someday then it's on sale always
remember that that's just an easy way to
keep in mind should i cash out should i
freak out
john we got to go back to that last
caller for a second because there's a
whole lot of that
in america today yeah okay there's a lot
of different ways that husbands and
wives
interact
over money
there's a situation where they work
together and everything's combined
and they make decisions together and
when they make decisions on their
spending and they're investing they
realize that they are truly adding a
level of unity a level of oneness to
their relationship a level of
communication their relationship and
that's plan a
and it has the highest probability of
increasing the quality of your marriage
and in the highest probability of you
becoming wealthy plan a does plan b
is to healthy mentally mature
emotionally mature people who operate
financially like roommates
but both of them have a vote and there
is a mutual respect and there's
communication between them but they run
separate accounts that's a plan b
there's a that lowers the probability of
wealth building and the quality of the
marriage substantially
but it still functions
uh
plan c that's even worse
uh
mom or dad husband or wife one of the
two is in charge
and the other one is doled out money
as an allowance well i gotta check with
mama see if i gain money
[Music]
meaning the wife is in charge of the
money or i gotta ask my husband because
he handles all the money
and uh or you know we don't i don't know
if we i don't know what we've got and
they die the one that handles the money
dies and the other one just left
clueless
and with no skills yeah because they
don't have decades of handling anything
they basically are a glorified child
being taken care of by an unglorified
parent yeah uh in that setting and that
is damaging to the relationship and it's
really
damaging to the money really damaging
the money
that
plan f where you fail the test
is one toxic member
of the team
is in control of the money and the other
person it's finance that's abuse with
toxic financial abuse right
the extreme of that
is there's a high correlation
in the data and in the actual practice
and i've seen it on the financial side
i've talked with other coaches you and i
have talked about this
you probably can cite a study i've just
talked to other people that have seen it
in practice that if if a husband has
extreme control
over the finances
to the point that the wife is not
allowed to make any can't go the grocery
store by herself she can't pay any
electric bill she's given two dollars at
a time
not two thousand dollars at a time
uh extreme control
probably 90 to 95 percent of the time
he's hitting her
domestic violence tied to that if
there's that level of control you can
just about count on it that last one
gets really close to that that's why my
first question was are you safe right
because you feel it she wanted to say
safe was emotional abuse but she's
upstairs and can't speak loudly because
he's downstairs that's right which makes
me wonder about that whole thing and how
many calls have we taken you and i have
taken that have a couple on they
disagree they're either laughing about
it or they're ingest but serious
that's the first one of these where
somebody's hiding upstairs saying
uh
help it it's
not yeah it's not the first one sadly
but it won't be the last one but the
point of us bringing this up is
i mean to outline what a plan is b plan
is c plan is and f plan is
here's the thing
every one of those regardless of who you
are and which player you are in that
role is a choice to go forward that way
right
and i would encourage every one of you
to choose to move towards the a plan
yeah
um or if you are unsafe to choose to get
out yeah
whether you're unsafe emotionally or
you're unsafe physically i don't i don't
tell people to file a divorce and i'll
tell people file bankruptcy but there
are situations where you're unsafe you
need to get out there and if you find
yourself she mentioned something at the
end of that call that
just has buried itself in my heart a
little bit she said
this isn't who i am
i i've looked up i bought this house i
bought on my own i had a great career i
was debt free
and now i'm somebody else that's common
language of somebody who's in an abusive
relationship i have become somebody else
in order to keep myself safe keep my
kids cave keep this guy free don't keep
his rage keep his rage down that's right
that's right and when you look in the
mirror and say who are you who have you
become because there's a rage person in
your life that is signal number one call
somebody and get some help right away
yep
yeah
absolutely that's um
the the wrathful man
proverbs talks about is a dangerous
character gal amen it's a dangerous
character and um
uh and the sad thing is is that he's
probably has very little coping skills
himself and that's what drives him to
rage that's right yeah
and he's get some i'd love for him to
get some help as well and she mentioned
something
the number of calls i'm taking dave on
my show the number the data is bearing
it out the folks over the last 24 months
who have gotten
psychotic about their cell phones and
new data and new information and news uh
it's destroying people put your phones
down and say i got a problem and go
re-engage or call it you get a human
being get a counselor yes you do not
need your
butcher turn your stupid screen off
get around human beings
i mean it's uh screen time
uh people have gone down the conspiracy
theory or
alternate theory or whatever you want to
call it uh rabbit hole and they live
there they live they've moved in yeah
and so i've had to put up a boundary in
my life i've got a certain number of
acquaintances slash friends that i'm
like
not here yeah i'm not i'm not talking
about cove anymore i'm tired of it there
you go it's not it's no longer fun i
don't want to talk about anymore yeah
because you're all stupid all of your
stuff
i'm just not talking about anymore you
know
and uh if i die from it y'all just y'all
make fun of me then that's fine but it's
all good and you can be mad at dave
ramsey and you're already mad at him so
screw it you know whatever it's okay so
um but i mean this whole thing you've
got a
this rage that has welled up inside of
the started with a quarantine
and has driven people the fear off of
that it's an existential crisis of
another kind it is and we are feeling a
mass
psychosis man we've got
dude and this is how nonsense gets
started dave that you can't wheel back
and so i want people to put their phones
down and go call a friend call and
ask your close buddies if i've been
raged out and if they're good friends
they'll be honest with you say now or
they'll look in and say yeah we've been
worried about you yeah i've had those
moments in my life man well you get in
fight mode and you stay jacked up and
you never get off you just go looking
for the next fight the next fight the
next fight yeah yeah and it's a jacked
up thing and then all you do is just
keep fox news on or cnn on whichever
version you are and they'll feed it to
you and they'll make sure you're pissed
off all 24 7. that's how they get paid
exactly and uh and if not you can turn
on your local news and a tornado's gonna
kill you but yeah
oh my god
there's a snowstorm
it's like oh geez
let's get in the truck and drive to work
or don't but pick one don't be ain't
gonna be
it's white powder it's going to be okay
you'll be all right and so um
yeah and but the the wussification
of america this idea that we don't know
how to fight through something and then
when we get into this
we don't have the the we don't have the
character structure to fight like a man
until we fight like a boy
and your power and control jacked up
chained
instead of
manly righteous anger at something
that's truly principled and wrong
and so you become an activist god help
you because you don't have anything else
to do
you know it's just it's weird it's weird
it's happening out there and so if
you're in those situations folks get get
some help call somebody please call
somebody get somebody in your corner
walk you walk you out of it and put the
phone down
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john deloney ramsey personality
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five tj is with us in lexington
kentucky hi tj how are you
i'm good thank you dave and john for
taking my call and i appreciate your
ministry and example to me and my family
and many others that uh
read your books and take your classes so
thank you well thank you sir you're very
kind how can we help today
so my question is my wife and i we're
both completely debt free
we're on baby step seven good and we've
got some cash that we're looking to
put into some real estate
[Music]
and to
rent out do some rentals
how many rentals do you have
i've had one in the past we currently
don't have any what's your name worth
not entering
about 2 million good for you well done
tj excellent job so now you're thinking
about buying some rental property okay
yeah we're looking to possibly get back
into it once your guidance and thoughts
on it but it's also two-fold my daughter
is looking to she's starting out her
career and we're looking to potentially
buy a condominium
and rent it out to her and another
roommate
um in in the meantime
and wanted to get your thoughts on that
okay
um
i would decide which it is is it your
daughter
or is it a rental property but i
wouldn't combine the two
um my daughter came out of college and i
was in right in the middle of buying a
bunch of property
and uh one of the properties i bought
was a really nice condominium like
you're describing
and she moved into it
and uh as a gift we let her live there
and we charged her roommates money they
were my tenants
and uh then when she got married later
uh she and her husband went on and did
their own thing
uh but that was just a way i could bless
her with having no rent but i'm not
gonna get in a thing where
this kid who's starting off her life is
writing a check to her millionaire daddy
okay i wouldn't do it i think it changes
the relationship
it's hard to be landlord-intended and
father and daughter
do you see why i appreciate your input
and advice do you see the difference
between if she
didn't want to get a job and she just
came home sometimes i'll tell people if
they're going to move back home they're
going to pay a rent in that room
one is you're trying to incentivize
um them to go out on their own the other
is you've got somebody who's
you've
you're able to bless your kid in this
way as they're launching off do you see
the difference there how much does the
conductor think about buying
it's around 300 000 okay how many kids
you got
have three okay all right
well at some point you could say um
i'm gonna buy you a condo and give it to
you uh if you wanted to
uh but on the if it were me it would be
like on the condition that you're living
life
well
and uh that this is a blessing to you
and on the condition that you promised
me you'll never borrow money
and uh then they can use that money that
they would have paid in a house payment
to become wealthy with quick
really quick
and uh you've changed that way you've
changed your family tree i'm not sure
you want to do that to the tune of 900
out of 2 million today
but at some point you'll be able to do
that and the first step could be buying
a condo for cash that you keep and she
lives there free
and then later on you might decide to do
some of that other stuff
but um i don't loan family members money
and i don't loan anybody money because
it changes the relationship the borrower
is slave to the lender i'll either give
it to you or i won't and i may give it
to you with a few strings attached that
i'll give it to you but you've got to go
through financial piece university and
get your crap together
you know you can get on a budget
and uh you know you're gonna have to be
you know come in
meet with one of our coaches and have
them coach you up on getting your budget
and getting your getting yourself on a
debt snowball and cutting up your credit
cards and if you do that we'll give you
the sex number dollars and get some
things started i had a friend of mine
from college that ended up homeless and
we're trying to help him get off the
street and that's what we did we got
bought him a car
put him up in a hotel
but it was on the condition that you
know he comes in and
does some work and comes in and does
some um coaching counseling so that we
fix the problem right you know that kind
of a thing but i don't i didn't i didn't
loan it to him right and i don't
i don't loan people money anybody but
certainly not my own kids and i'm not
going to charge them around either so
that that's the reason i don't want to
change thanksgiving dinner just tastes
weird when you eat with your landlord
it's just weird and it certainly changed
if you owe them money it changes
everything so
um you've got the right heart and you've
got the right mind you're trying to not
be an enabler and allow her to be lazy
but i think that's already settled i
don't think she's lazy right you never
mentioned a thing about her being off
kilter and if she was off kilter you
would have said so and if she works for
six months and decides she's just
working so hard i just don't wanna i'm
tired they're rude and she's gonna stay
at home for six months then we may talk
about okay if you're gonna live in my
house then
working is part of the equation work
he's part of your free rent here yeah
you get to work you have to you have to
you know i'm not i'm not setting up a
thing where your trust fund baby sitting
on the back of a yacht right um
eating
whatever or whatever you do on the back
of a yacht but um
but the bon bons that's it lady in the
in the audience just said it thank you
thank you but yeah i don't even know
what you did but see she knows but yeah
but the uh uh yeah that that's it and
i'm lip reading today too that's not bad
i don't know that i've ever had a bon
bon i think i'm gonna make it a priority
to try them out as shows you know what
you could switch out bon bons for gummy
bears
i don't think that gummy bears for bon
bons you could be john has a bon bon
problem that would be interesting
kelly's like please replace that no
please don't have that
problem all right let's go who is next
let's break this up bryce is in st
george utah hey bryce what's up
gents i appreciate the time i'm looking
for uh your opinion on whether i'm
stupid or not and i'll take it
constructively
yes we're good at this
good um i recently uh moved of my
employment i was full-time making around
180 i moved it to part-time so i make
around 90 now so that my wife could
pursue this dream of starting a business
basically she's a cpa so she started a
cpa firm in an online course
she makes around 300 part-time
she's done extremely well i couldn't be
more proud of her wow
but
i'm i'm kind of holding her back by
still working 20 hours a week and i love
my job i love my career i'm an actuarial
consultant i've i like building
relationships i like talking to people
sorry go ahead how are you holding her
back
well
if i
quit my career and it really completely
took over the kids and the house and all
that she could make another 300 plus
she's only working 30 hours 40 hours a
week right now yeah but you love what
you do she could be doing more yeah you
make half a million dollars numerically
it's stupid
hire some help man
all right
it's not stupid how are you
you get you get you get satisfaction out
of your work she gets satisfaction out
of her work
um we're not abandoning the children
we're not sending them to boarding
school
uh we're gonna still be there and love
them both of you are working part-time
already you said she's working part-time
making 300 you're working part-time
making 90. and so you know if she wants
to gear up a little bit you want to gear
up a little bit that's fine and uh you
know you're not gonna i don't we're not
suggesting you work 80 hours a week but
if you go from 20 hours to 30 hours a
week and you go from
390 to whatever hire a nanny it's not
that big a deal
is there a level of
bryce just shut up and be grateful for
what you have like we don't need more
we're very frugal we're natural favors
it's
it just feels dumb
no it doesn't eating potential
it's not a matter of being greedy or
ambitious
your wife enjoys what she's doing and
she's enjoying the success
of growing this thing and she wants to
do more of that
yep
and i often hear it on the other side
when my wife has a or my husband's got a
hobby and he's not making any money at
it
and as long as it's not detracting from
the family then
it's the same thing except this one just
earns three to six hundred thousand
dollars right yeah
uh you know you feed ambition to the
point that it's not workaholism and to
the point that you're blessing others
and your family is not out of kilter
right your family's not off bubble this
is about joy this is just about finding
a little bit better balance and it's
hard for
people that are doing this to actually
pay someone else to come in and help
yeah it's a hard thing to do it's a good
thing to do
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
proverbs 25 21 is our scripture of the
day if your enemy is hungry give him
food to eat if he is thirsty give him
water to drink
benjamin franklin says love your enemies
for they tell you your faults
hey i love that welcome to twitter who
said that
benjamin franklin i've never heard that
quote love your enemies for they tell
you your faults
there's a lot of love out there for you
dave
[Laughter]
janelle is in tacoma washington hi
janelle welcome to the ramsey show
hello
hi what's up um
uh well i have a question i just want to
say thank you so much
my husband and i have been doing the
plan since march of 2020 and so far
we've paid off almost 60 thousand
dollars way to go wow
yeah
yeah we should be out of bed by the end
of this year good for you well done
proud of you
um
so
my question is my husband's car it died
over the weekend
and he has a weird car or i feel like
the engine was put in upside down
because the starter is in a weird place
in the alternator you have to like
pull the engine out in order to fix it
so we're looking at probably an 800 to 2
000
repair for his
uh mazda
and it's it's older it's got a 150 000
miles on it
um
and we're wondering
at what point
do we say go ahead and fix it at what
point would you be like
i'll just
try and sell it as is and
how much money do you have in savings
um we have the thousand dollar emergency
fund and um as the month goes on we kind
of put aside all the stuff
uh for the end of the month for us to
pay on to our debt so we can take
all of what we were going to pay on our
debt how much is that that's the
thousand dollar emergency fund how much
is that uh so that should be about 3 500
so you got 4 500
and you have an 800 repair what's the
car worth if it were fixed
if it's fixed and we're gonna sell it
just personal uh private sale it's
probably we could probably get about six
grand for it six thousand dollars
and if you don't fix it you can get one
thousand dollars for it
okay
maybe
one thousand sizes really yeah
so you spend eight hundred dollars on it
even if you're going to sell it
yes because otherwise you get a cut of
five thousand dollars instead of a cut
of eight hundred dollars you go from six
thousand value to one thousand dollars
in value if you don't fix it even if
you're going to sell it you fix it
and you sell it for six thousand
if it's not the starter though then it
could be like a two thousand dollar fix
because we have to lift this you're
still selling it for six thousand
yeah
so you're gonna you're gonna fix the car
and you're gonna get more than one
opinion because so far what we have is a
bunch of freaking theories we're going
to actually analyze what's wrong with
this car and be dealing with facts not
theories
right now you're dealing with a worry
and a problem you don't have the facts
to solve the problem the facts are
two different people have actually
looked at this that know how to fix it
and have given you two separate bids
that will fix it and they have diagnosed
the exact problem
okay and if that's 962 dollars you're
going to spend it to fix it and then you
can decide if you want to keep it or not
but here's the thing you can sell it for
six thousand dollars and buy another six
thousand dollar car
and stay right on your plan minus the
800 that you had to come up with the 800
is your car repair that's used up your
emergency fund so you got to turn around
and put 1000 back in the emergency fund
because you spent on this car but that
other than that you're gonna figure
you're gonna fix the car
you're gonna fix the car would you
recommend okay yes i think you're tired
of it i think you're sick of fixing a
car that's uh that's this is the third
time you've dealt with it being upside
down and all the engines upside down all
that and so it sounds like you're tired
of the car
i'm a little bit tired of the car but my
husband is not and it's his car
well the question is financially is the
car good for our family if the car is
okay to keep driving for a while after
we fix it then keep it and drive it i
don't care if you keep it or not
okay but i think you're gonna spend an
eight to eight hundred dollars on a six
thousand dollar car now let's change the
equation for a second for example
purposes so you kind of know how i made
this decision
all right let's say that the car was a
true hoop d and it was worth two
thousand dollars
but you can sell it for twelve hundred
dollars salvage
well i'd sell it for salvage
because i don't put 800 in a 2 000 car
because the difference in the salvage i
is a break even
but the difference in this one is 5 000
drop in value due to an 800 repair
but you don't put in the car if you put
more into the car than it raises it in
value then you don't do it
okay in this case it's going to raise it
in value a lot more by fixing it
even if you're going to sell it and that
tells you how to work this out in the
future but some of you are out there
driving two thousand dollar hoopties
right now and you're in the middle of
your baby step two and those are those
are throwaway cars garage sale cars you
buy them at a garage sale and when they
break down you sell them for salvage and
you throw them away and you get you
another garage sale car and you keep
going i've done that i've driven those
guys too they're no fun their car you
give a name to take a picture of to tell
your grandchildren this is what it's
like back in the days of all 22
when we was getting out of debt you know
respect before we had no money for i had
10 million
the names i had for some of those cars
in my life i don't think i could tell my
kids they were not nice names i had one
that was the predominant color on it was
bondo
we called it the bondo buggy that was
its name old blue the bondo buggy
and the vinyl roof was torn loose across
the front so when you drove it it filled
up with air like a parachute yeah so i'm
classing it down the road with this
parachute on top of this bondo buggy
and um yeah
stop
come back down then you take off again
and go back up and that's how you know
if you ever wondered if sharon really
loved me yep
uh sharon would have left but she didn't
have a car i was like a car
so yeah
oh that was it man whoa that was fun not
really oh man so uh the bondo buggy yeah
well i mean you got to have you got to
name it and we had a we had a uh george
and i were pulling him up in here the
other day because we were looking for a
car i'm trying to get george to buy a
car because he's paid off his house it's
time for him to buy a car it's
ridiculous
he's driving that hooptie of a honda out
there
and so he's cheap george is cheap
i am too many more he spent more on his
friends bulldog he's other level that's
right his his little different designer
dog he bought a little designer double
big ears but yeah it's a cute dog but
the uh um but yeah the uh uh
i you know i remember i bought sharon a
pinto
that was um a 19 i think it was a 72
and it was uh like um kind of forest
green yeah really seriously ugly this
car
i mean it was the it was the old version
of a ford fiesta yeah it was an absolute
piece of crap
i mean when the gearbox and that thing
when you change the gears it was like
changing gears in your riding lawnmower
you know how they feel oh yeah
you know it's like you change gears you
would feel every movement of the stupid
thing it was and and i swear the clutch
was like a rotting lawnmower clutch the
engine was less powerful than my riding
one more i had an 88 tercel easy
hatchback when i drove it my knees were
up here around my shoulders because it
was so little oh yeah i sold it
for a hundred bucks
the
hatchback
yeah you could you could haul you three
or you could have a deer i could put my
get my guitar amps back there i sell it
for 300 bucks and some college kids
eventually took it out into a field and
drove it till it stopped that's that's
where that car died i got a call about
three years later from uh they drove it
in the field and and they buried it they
thought it'd be hilarious just for the
actual they're just gonna drive it into
the woods until it just quits running
and that was their fun for the night
that's how beat up this car was and then
i got a call about three years later
from a storage saying i owe them a whole
bunch of money i guess somebody towed it
out of their field years later but that
was my tercel and i'm going to find one
for that's me my son's first car so you
didn't transfer the title you left oh no
i sold it too yeah how did it how did
you get charged
no well cause i sold it to my brother i
didn't want to throw him out on the
radio but there you go
he's the one who did it he needs to pay
for the storage well they said you can
either uh
give us the car or pay us however two or
three thousand bucks and i said merry
christmas you are the new owners of
she's got you a guard of an old tercel
hat you've got a car buddy
call your friends
you can't make this stuff up
uh and you won't hear this on any other
radio show i'll just tell you this is
big time entertainment you should have
pinto i'm gonna bite yourself we're
gonna race
that'll
get my lawnmower out that'll put this
hour in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you